it goes back to the basic idea of why
are we studying a language hi there
Steve coffin here and today I want to
talk about what is the most important
thing in language learning the most
important thing in language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications and if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a comment
so what's important in language learning
the answer is quite simple
what is important in language learning
is whatever is important to you the
learner all right
and I'll explain what I mean by that
you'll remember or those of you who
follow me will remember the three keys
to language learning which I often refer
to something that I heard at a language
Teachers Conference in San Diego many
years ago and a very experienced person
with many years of teaching told me that
there are only three things that matter
in language learning the attitude of the
learner the time spent with the language
not reading grammar in your native
language but actually with the language
listening reading speaking writing and
the third thing is the ability to notice
and that is a little more difficult to
understand but if we do research on
things that we notice in life we notice
things that are important to us
and so the importance of things becomes
a big factor in language acquisition
and I I thought of doing this video
because I noticed
that I was listening to a mini story in
Persian for them I don't know 30th time
and I noticed something about verbs and
or particular a particular verb in
Persian that I hadn't noticed before
why did I notice it I didn't
deliberately sort of plan to notice that
but probably in the sort of evolution of
my learning of Persian I'm now sort of
open to noticing something which has now
become important to me because I noticed
that I'm struggling with certain you
know patterns of verbs in Persian
and so then I noticed this thing in in
this story
it's not that I set out you know I'm
gonna listen to this story and I'm gonna
deliberately notice the verbs or
something like that no it's just that I
was ready to notice this particular verb
and structure
and having noticed it there and I'll
probably notice it again I think we've
all had the experience that once you
notice something somewhere you'll notice
it in other places and eventually then
hopefully that then becomes a pattern
that I will recognize and that I'll be
able to use but it begins with the idea
that this now is important for me uh you
know I remember when I was learning
Chinese characters and of course
teachers like to teach you things that
they think are important so the teacher
decides what's important so they taught
me that the Chinese characters have
these radicals these components that
represent either meaning or in many
cases the sound of the character
but it made no you know impression on me
I couldn't really recognize them it
didn't really help me learn the
characters I still felt that I had to
learn each character individually much
much later I began to see the importance
of these radicals or components in the
Chinese characters
it's like uh you know the teacher again
I've mentioned this before people who
um write textbooks for languages feel
that they they want to start with
in in some in many languages
relatives you know your uncle on your
mother's side on your father's side your
older sister your younger sister they
all have different names and so people
want to teach this to you right up front
and I always find that this is like of
no interest to me at this point it's not
important to me there's so many other
things that I need to learn about the
language that this simply is not
important uh textbooks like to introduce
festivals to you again it may be
important to some beginners not
important to me at a later stage in my
learning I will find those things very
interesting and therefore important
um you know some textbooks like to teach
you all the colors at once it's not
important to me and therefore I can't
learn them when a particular color
becomes important I will notice it and I
will learn it
um you know I was thinking too it's a
bit like when we drive a car
uh if we approach an intersection
um I now as a driver with many many
years of experience I'm looking for cars
that might be coming from the right hand
side or the left-hand side maybe they
aren't maybe they're going to run the
intersection uh I'll notice for example
if I'm going to turn right on a red
light which I'm allowed to do uh are
there pedestrians Crossing or attempting
to cross the intersection there's so
many things that I naturally notice that
are important to me but at an early
stage as a driver when I'm struggling
with my manual gear shift or other
things in the car that are more
important to me I don't notice these
things or I might notice from the car
that there's a new restaurant
that's just opened up in my uh area of
town and I'll notice a restaurant but I
won't notice for example a nail salon
because I'm not interested in nail
salons but I'm interested in restaurants
restaurants are important to me it goes
back to the basic idea of why are we
studying a language if learning that
language is not important to you you
won't learn uh if the time you spend
trying to learn that language is not an
important use of time you won't learn
the more you can seek out a content of
Interest content that is important to
you to learn from the better you're
going to learn
if there are issues of grammar that are
important to you you so important that
you actually Google for them or look
through a grammar book and look them up
at a time when they are important to you
you're more likely to learn them if the
teacher decides okay class today we're
going to learn the subjunctive and you
are struggling with so many other the
things in the language that this
explanation of the subjunctive makes no
impression on you because you're not
ready to receive that information you
don't have other relevant information or
knowledge to make it more meaningful
it's not important to you so there are
so many ways in which what's important
in language learning
is is what's important to us whether it
be in terms of the the language content
that we learn from or the aspects of the
language that we want to learn about or
simply the fact that a natural process
of
you know having more and more pieces of
the jigsaw puzzle of that language
have been put on the board and so now
you are able to focus on the missing
pieces these missing pieces are now
important to you
so uh I think the ability to to notice
is because we notice things that are
important to us it's it's in many ways a
subconscious uh process but at the same
time you have to be open you're not
going to notice things if you're not
open uh open to new
um sights and sounds open to new ways of
pronouncing things open to new ways of
saying things if you are open to these
things and the language is important to
you gradually more and more aspects of
that language will become important you
will acquire them initially passively
and then eventually you'll be able to
use them uh when speaking
so I'll leave you with a video that I
did about
um
you know the noticing hypothesis which
is part of the sort of linguistics World
explaining how we learn
and also an old video on the importance
of choosing content of interest to learn
from so thank you for listening bye for
now